im scheinwerferlicht stehen das innerste
nach außen kehren masochistischen
tendenzen in kauf nehmen dass ein witz
floppt damit leben dass die karriere
jederzeit enden kann
wer auf der bühne steht muss sich warm
anziehen
man muss sich öffnen wird damit
angreifbar verletzbar
das risiko muss mit nico wenn wir das
bin ich dort wir treffen michael von der
heide im zürcher theater am hechtplatz
jahr feiert der chansonnier sein 25
jahre bühnenjubiläum mit einer hommage
an paula
vor der premiere durch wälzten echte das
risiko zu scheitern verfolgt in oft bis
in den schlaf immer relativ großer saal
sehen ist eine gute stimme hat wie
könnten machen
okay okay manchmal gibt es allerdings
auch ein böses erwachen wie bei der
vorausscheidung des eurovision song
contest 1999
auch elf jahre später war ihm beim
zweiten halbfinal in oslo kein erfolg
beschieden
nichts mit gold von der heide wurde
letzter ein schock davon erholte er sich
dank seiner großen erfahrung für mich
ist ob sie ganz nah von gts talent
wettbewerb mitgemacht haben kann ich mal
verloren kann ich wieder mal ohne und
das verlieren oder wenn technik gurus
das hat mir immer kraft gehen das hat
nicht immer der rockerkrieg
weitergemacht wenn man also dass ich
damals auch sie in oslo
das hat nicht wisst dass ich für mich
nicht als ein von ihm von meiner
karriere sondern rück und scor sache zu
konzentrieren und nimmst die andere
projekt der inhalt einer lektion die
auch seine realen lernen musste
mit lunik mischte sie 15 jahre lang an
der spitze der schweizer musikszene mit
dann 2013 das aus
sogar das geld weiter das gibt
wahnsinnige kraft und energie hat die
karten neu gemischt
scharf und accords heißt denn auch ihr
erstes soloalbum die produktion ein
risiko denn keiner schweizer
plattenfirma wollte sie dabei
unterstützen
er gründete ihre eigene
trotz jahrzehntelangem erfolg sitzt die
angst vor rückschlägen bei der schlatter
tief nicht immer ist das publikum so
begeistert wie hier dann geht's ans
eingemachte funktioniert will erfolglos
und meist gleiter war schlatter in
jungen jahren eine tragische erfahrung
die er im film komiker verarbeitete das
gute chromik aus angst unser hund
probiert immer dann zu überdecken
oder eben hat der motivation der
top-figur das ist motivation der komik
dient
sich das zunutze machen und das risiko
des künstlerdasein es mit humor tragen
keine schlechte strategie ebenso
relativieren und abstrahieren damit die
leidenschaft nicht zur hellen kreide
es gibt immer so lüth bühnenkünstler
applaus ganz früher mit ihm verwechselt
und applaus ist tatsächlich wichtig und
nötig und sind streicheleinheit aber das
ist nicht die begrenzte eine bühnenreife
einsicht risiken und nebenwirkungen
bleiben dennoch teil des spiels